[Musique]
vestige de l'île bourbon la saline de
saint-leu possède des derniers bassens
alain à la réunion à l'extrémité de la
pointe au sel son musée propose aux
visiteurs de partir à la découverte de
son histoire et de la fabrication du sel
à l'arrêt n'y pleut musée c'est une
façon théorique d'expliquer comment on
produit le 7 6 alors auto série voilà
donc il ya une partie visites
extérieures mais une partie intérieure
où on découvre comment quelles sont les
conditions exceptionnelles que nous
prouve que ce cyber frédéric mora et
sony ils sont sept comme lui à perpétuer
la tradition de ce métier sur les
salines de salins un savoir faire et une
histoire qu'ils partagent avec les
visiteurs c'est normal c'est historique
c'est quand même eux
ainsi que la serre et toute la
communauté réunionnaise yoplait ce site
a été créé qu'en dans la guerre ben
tout est rentré dans l'île et
d'après les anciens leurs intérêts dans
les deux mois qui viennent rappeler
celle sur le site
le dial a vraiment utile économiquement
mais je dise
il faut essayer d'en haut niveau
[Musique]